[Musique]
on est en jeu
pour rappel 35 heures de direct
ça fait 4 enfin des avants on a déjà
fait quatre heures on nous aurait trompé
lui il n'ya catherine euros pour
l'association c'est que du bonheur et
nous sommes devant camille et babar très
spécial il conçoit qu'alibaba c'est
l'émission spéciale
et si vous nous rejoignez ça c'est qu'il
y a deux équipes l'équipe jaune dont qui
est mon équipe composée de jean michel
mr capucine adam julien pasquet et
gilles verdez qui est en position là 2,9
et il ya l'équipe de camille rocailleux
avec fabien lecoeuvre ça sandra sandra
ramon a dit exactement voilà tient qu'à
change de nom tous les soirs vous voilà
à stéphanie mémoire exceptionnelle bien
sûr et benjamin castaldi merci c'est
l'équipe de camille pour l'instant on a
fait trois épreuves
et là c'est la deuxième de deuxième
partie donc de ceux de cette émission
d'accueillir il reste pas mal d'épreuves
auxquelles il reste plein d'épreuves les
a lus avant que tpp arrive aussi en
direct de bien sûr il ya plein plein
plein d'épreuves et parier sur l'équipe
qui vous pensez sera la gagnante hashtag
team camí ou hashtag simba bas et parmi
les bonnes réponses
combien parier que tu en veux repartir
avec un très très beau cadeau une
tablette ont à ce jour colère la brocade
obtenu en fin d'émission est pour
l'instant ces deux mois qu'on sert il et
un toit pour mon équipe c'est très serré
donc allé il ya aussi on mettra aussi
des images d'un des preuves voilà un peu
de roulement et c'est ce qu'on m'avait
dit abdoul le producteur assure abdul
apparemment est en rtt d'accord à bien
il ya des images ou pas aussi dans
l'émission à 12 ce sera demain sur voilà
allez merci
abdul voilà bah ça c'est la méthode
abdul voilà ce que avec tout ce que ça
comporte
alors juste on m'a dit dans mon oreille
chez remy d'un mec qui fait du vélo sur
votre plateau oui c'est moi on va
rappeler son identité quand vous appelez
vous monsieur pascal pascal comment le
grand frère pascal et pour pascal que
j'aime il ça fait 4 heures qui pédalent
parce que nous on fait les malins
le livre c'est de battre le record il va
essayer de pédaler pendant les 35 heures
c'est quoi le record postale
bastian alors en fait j'en détiens
disent les records du monde et j'ai été
cinq fois champion du monde donc j'en ai
exemple c'est pas rigolo donc à la
l'objectif c'est de faire plus de 1000
bornes quoi ouais on est en a combien la
140 et quelque chose 140 ben déjà fait
mais bon bah écoute donc pascal sera là
normalement pendant les 35 heures mais
chine
mais c'est vrai donc voilà il adore
pascal si tu as un problème tu ta but à
manger et a pris des mois ça va c'est
qu'il faut c'est vrai si tu veux tu
pédales à ta place au numéro d'accord
merci
camille yahi l'épreuve
tu vas arriver également dans l'instant
c'est l'épreuve du coup de poing et ça
je l'attends avec impatience pour le
moment en plus t'as castaldi dans ton
équipe qui tape et qui cogne fort
attention pour le moment c'est le
curling humain donc comment ça se passe
mais camille c'est très sain chacun
notre tour on va lancer une personne de
notre équipe et ce sera en deux points
gagnants à chaque fois là qui est le
plus près de la cible on les ramène le
premier en deux points
l'accord marque le point on a des balles
et non se servir à passer comme le
curling ça sert à ça parce que c'était
juste pour faire genre voilà les deux
candidats adultes auraient mieux fait de
sortir des images voilà j'ai pas de
ballet merci à eybens meilleur
d'ailleurs on offre ses deux balles est
d'ailleurs un téléspectateur amassé
reste à bordeaux
on apprend tout autre émission hashtag
deux ballets et vous repartez avec ses
deux balles et voilà on prendre à
quelqu'un au sort et on le prendra même
à l'antenne pour le froid les balles est
d'accord on est content on allait
camille on y va donc tu veux démarrer
monkam y aller je démarre tu démarres
avec fabien lecoeuvre voilà qui est bien
compact on rappelle fabien lecoeuvre
vous savez comment on appelle dans le
métier le rubik's cube sera donc il est
bien kouba qu il est bien dans sa tête à
ça sur ses partisans masqués dans ton
équipe mais je crois que c'est julien
paquet - dans la merde en mai fut don
vito
c'est un autre volcan
bidon mais non non mais le mec je n'ai
jamais vu un tel pas qui est vraiment au
dessus des grès le mec il a qu'a dit
avec des courses dans son slip le talent
est là
il a d'abord nié il a ainsi mené avec
des courses des sacs de pommes de terre
mais sans déconner c'est un trio alors
attention on a l'impression qu'il a les
buzzer de question pour l'instant
qu'elle est calé attention quelle est la
capitale de la bulgarie à l'avocat mills
est partie au fou à l'aironi va falloir
pousser tout ça allait aller camille
pas mal du tout aisée loi qui attention
gilles le casque est très dense et si
oui mais toi en position aérodynamique
avec le nez bien en avant par josette
trop fort non
en fort
[Musique]
mais blake la côte est attention là on
refait on va quand on a droit parce que
j'ai l'impression de la personne ou en
devenir maintenant font venir des
mercenaires engagés par six prochaines
années
vraiment on refait avec les dom est en
fait qu les domaines où la longe et il
est trop grave sur l'argile à les
skippers heures mais on est vraiment
obligé de remettre le cas moi je pense
pas non mais c'est pas non plus très
très dangereux voilà c'est pas de toute
façon je crois que c'est pas la plus
grosse zone à protéger
je suis d'accord avec amy si vous donnez
s'il ya une zone à protéger je pense que
le casque il faut plutôt mettre ici non
vraiment où est ce que vous avez volé sa
jeunesse à défaut mais j'ai l'impression
qu'ils ont rangé la table de ping-pong
entière mais c'est pas possible ça a
décollé
[Applaudissements]
mais si vous n'auriez hoya quelqu'un
réponde et nous on joue ce soir je
regardais attention regardez regardez je
vais essayer de vous faire je vais
essayer de vous faire deviner un titre
grâce à ta grâce à son site
c'était pas ça je voulais faire je
voulais faire je vais faire quand je
vois tes yeux je suis amoureux
malheureusement je ne peux pas les voir
je suis ap bravo en tout cas bravo très
belle très belle prestation
allez allez attention m elle alors non
non et tourne face à l'émotion
si je le mets si je le mets c'est gagné
allez babar
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est moins loin
zéro point chacun les ronds points
chacun euros pour chacun il ya donc
toujours 2.1 pour mon équipe qu'amicale
et la prochaine épreuve
la prochaine épreuve elle est très
simple on envoie le jingle je vous
explique ça dans une seconde ça va être
de la culture générale mais en même
temps de la peur c'est le coup de bol
jingle en espoirs
[Applaudissements]
le coup de bol le principe il est très
simple cyril et moi nous allons chacun
de choisir je sens que je vais aimer le
coup de bol d'une souris moi je n'y
trouve pas on va on va demander un autre
a disaster kiraly l'émission les chéris
s'il vous plaît keira 10 émissions
didier fraisse d'idées froehly enfin
c'est didier quelqu'un alors didier
fraisse montdidier
j'aimerais qu'on vient de faire voilà un
plan sur tout ce qui se passe regardez
donc camille qu'est ce qui va se passer
il ya donc décret simple non on va
chacun d'être ici cyril et à l'intérieur
vous le voyez il y a des questions à
l'intérieur de chaque bol on va chacun
choisir une fille de l'équipe de chaque
équipe et qui va ensuite avoir une
minute pour tirer le maximum de
questions et y a pas peur c'est des amis
et réceptions et ricitiello
éventuel e maximum de questions en dix
minutes on devra répondre alors la
particularité cyril évidemment en une
minute maximum de questions arrête
arrête un regard tout cela s'est passé
donc ils sont protégés et le principe il
est très simple si ed plus c'est entre
guillemets dégoûtant et ça fait peur
plus les questions sont faciles cercle
avec les asticots les questions sont
beaucoup plus difficiles donc plus vous
avez de courage pour nora des chances de
répondre allemand avec cyril d'accord
une où on nous posera les questions
championnat j'ai rien compris mais je me
sens bien c'est très simple accord donc
on va envoyer des gens chaque fois
piocher pour nous poser la guerre votre
tour vous avez joué avec capucine et je
vais jouer avec stéphane d'accord
excusez moi juste comme il faut deux
points abaissé celui qui fait le plus de
points et demi non en une minute moi je
pense qu'il faut peut-être faire un truc
c'est 3 pour le premier à trois points
gagnants comme ça ok premier entre
autres points alors attention et comme
consignes et stéphanie venir
alors la piscine mais c'est pourquoi
vous faites ça c'est horrible
non c'est pas horrible ça c'est la vie
les animaux c'est la vie moi ça je peux
pas non mais ce n'est là ce serait tout
ça les uns et red bull je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui les animaux c'est la vie si
vous n'aimez pas les animant ce n'est
même pas des hommes c'est perdre à
jamais diminué mais pas les rats vous
n'aimez pas les q allez vous n'aimez pas
le cas je vous dis donc
attention on va démarrer avec votre
équipe avec stéphane j'ai juste une
chose très importante pour vous les
filles on ne touche que où les serpents
ou les rapa les deux parce que le
serpent lra après ça peut les énerver
donc vous choisissez que où les rats où
les serbes sont pas les mêmes élèves à
widnes aussi aussi entre grands fonds en
tout cas ne fait pas que l'odeur ça se
passe ta g et c'est laval pour les emmy
à côté exactement
on a été malin est-ce que les serpents
peuvent mordre alors un serpent peu
morne un serpent a déjà mordu en 1872
técher et d'émissions ne m'excuse hélas
on est ce qu est-ce qui sont martèle ce
sont des alors ce sont les charmants ce
sont des serpents tout ce qui est le
plus mortel ne vous inquiétez pas à un
dock vous permet d'aller vous agrée pas
j'y suis allé alors on y va donc alors
là elle va poser une question avoue
camille c'est le premier arrivé à troyes
exactement
attention à chaque question qu'est ce
que c'est alors ça ça c'est de la
famille c'est de la famille alors une
grenouille mâle et f6 si vous partez là
dessus elles seront un peu plus facile
pour moi les questions attendait veut
partir sur ça c'est moi non plus et vous
tous et vous capital et les astros ses
mines allez on y va aller ça y est c'est
fini
à la question pourquoi
question pour canal qui présente le 20
heures de tf1 le week end eux
c'est à mai et c'est c je ne sais quoi
coudray année se termine et non en
poudre et coudre et bas jamais quand
même faudrait faut le prénom ses amants
j'allais dire claire coudray sommes sur
une mauvaise réponse est pas bon on a la
rage
c'était bien c'était bien cool dre nadia
recouvert d'or c'est anne claire coudray
recherche en faudrait bien compter des
réponses aussi sur les papiers merci à
doullens facile et plus dur ça attention
écoutez je vais vous dire de bouder ne
vous connais pas la traiter facile s'il
ya 2 0 0 on va dire c'est le premier à
doha bon ok ok des questions il est plus
facile celle là je ne sais pas non mais
c'est pas ça valera vous avez vous deja
non mais je suivais pas une question sur
les rails peut pas y sont cachés
non mais c'est moi qui vais répondre à
la question comment vous aurez pas
choisi bout
r
capucine sinon j'aurais été piocher et
vous vous aurais répondu aux questions
d'un côté je vais prendre les i dans les
asticots comme ça qu'on est comme ça qu
on surnomme dans le milieu du sexe non
ils vont pas sauter à l'état pur alors
attendez avant tout ce que vous savez
lire
à levac a pu alors là si vous savez pas
comment s'appelle la copine de mickey
mouse mickey mouse cdi
[Applaudissements]
ces non dits je ne connais que je les
mêmes chine et il ya ces rodéos non
parce que tu parles c'est une cata aller
attention tu finis les serpents pas est
simple est-ce que ça c'est des iguanes
alors ça ça peut arracher un mois les
ouates
ça sent bizarre trop chou
bah oui mais c'est sûr que ces appareils
sont pas habitués sont pas remis du
déodorant aller sauf à l'espèce est
loyal et faut y aller alors on peut pas
réutiliser deux fois la même chose on
non trop facile qui était surnommé le
king of pop
alors ben c'est ce qui s'est passé c'est
lisse
[Applaudissements]
ouais comme ça
king of pop michael jackson indépendant
lequel région attendez je suis assez
d'accord avec lui il a toujours choisi
king's quest ix les gars je vous
rappelle que c'est le premier de points
je pense que ce jeu peut durer pendant
35 heures hélas oui alors vous allez
choisir quoi tu sais quoi vous voulez
quoi au général est regrettable dans les
rangs un arrêt dans la canopée n'ont pas
l'air à palerme à la question
le problème c'est que pour l'instant
capucine et stéphanie font le boulot et
nous derrière on appelle t-on les
glandes qui secrètes les larmes de nos
yeux les glandes lacrymales
à moins les meilleurs choix et question
john un point donc il y a et c'est le
premier arrivé à deux points qui gagnent
cette épreuve à semsales est jeune et on
il allait chercher ses gouaches
[Applaudissements]
gardez un oeil en a même un qui
s'appelle gonzalo c'est pourquoi la
sphère des fonds s'envole mais il bouge
trop mais ils sont sur les nerfs vert et
sont gentilles contrat gentil
alizée haye
[Musique]
allez y allez
allez vous allez laissez vous ne
passerez pas de faire
[Applaudissements]
maîtresse à baraf hachoir
[Musique]
wallez email
[Applaudissements]
vous l'avez vous allez
allez c'est le papier la tue des touches
pas [ __ ] papier qu'elle touche bordel
merci bravo à camille albane on a su
aller je fais le boulot là ce thème
n'est ce pas tellement attention ça les
yeux remplis sur sa vespa après jo
après joe qui est le plus petit des
frères dalton jack question je sais pas
moi dit non c'est un vrai eldorado jack
williams joe jack williams pas vrai
parce que moi je pense que c'est william
un nom mais on n'est pas chez st arnaud
va poser des questions a donné la
réponse est oui dit jacques audiard
jacques audiard est un dj qui dit
williams maintenant il a dit jack hockey
afghans c'est jack russel williams
chez rhodia attention si on gagne si on
répond bien prenez ça irait sous les
serpents ou ça écoeure non non mais
alors c'est rien ou si on répond bien à
cette question on a gagné
allez on y va qui a pu tuer tu es
formidable à regarder quelle pagaille
regarde pas car ici scénario si je
réponds bien cette fois on aura donc le
deuxième point qui nous fera gagner là
si vous répondez pas franchement mais
moi je sais j'étais un gars y at il deux
roues sur un tricycle deux roues d'euros
alors généralement je vais vous dire sur
un tricycle tri c'est à dire de trop
donc forcément il ya trois roues sur un
tri si c'est donc la bonne réponse
parfois il peut y avoir un quatrième si
c'est un round puis ma série
exceptionnelle
victime du parti à nice en attendant
bravo à state les capucines parce que
camier moi on aime et capucine estèphe
vous avez de mettre minable et celle ci
est battu mettez le nez pendant cette
pause
alors qu'amy pour l'instant il n'y a
qu'au ps qu'on peut voir les scores si
vous comptez parmi l'équipe de bab à
voir s'ils croient points 1,3 point là à
l'est rien n'est fait puisque maintenant
donc serré nous mais on va partir en
bagarre là maintenant il va falloir de
la force pour y jouer avec cette machine
je vous connaissez c'est une épreuve de
force qui calcule la force avec le point
les amis c'est parti c'est le ti punch
on appelait ça comme ça
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'à lui vous allez expliquer la
règle mais je crois connaître on va tous
passer à shaktoi le plus petit score
sera éliminé exactement c'est bien fait
le plus petit score a été éliminé à
chaque fois et il en restera plus qu'à
notre attention mettez vous en s'il vous
plaît pour l'épreuve suivante cyril on
va faire sortir fabien et gilles parce
qu'ils ont besoin d'être préparé
puisqu'ils vont représenter chacun leur
équipe dans un instant d'accord fabien
gilles vous sortez vos places dès allez
on
attention c'est l'oignon pense quoi
calmer baba je vous rappelle il est
18h30 nous sommes en direct depuis 14h à
bien sûr on a eu la première émission
touche pas à mes après-midi et là nous
sommes dans l'élan pau soit 15000 baba
spécial épreuve et mon camille équipe
jaune contre l'équipe rouge pour
l'instant l'équipe jose mène trois
points à 1
et là on va tous donc cogner et à chaque
fois le plus petit score sera éliminé
plus petit score éliminé on va aller
très vite
benjamin je compte sur toi sur celle là
on est parti justement il y en a plus et
on y va on parle je ne joue pas je donne
un coup de main c'est exactement ce imad
hanna way de tout ce que tu veux tu peux
attention il va tu vas te blesser
bêtement
[Applaudissements]
4 heures
et non puisse encore énorme score tuer
vous êtes sûr qu'elle est bonne la
machine puissante norbert lammert bon
alors on ne faut qu'on mette à 0 merci
si on est à 0 garder bien et ce quand
j'ai vu remettre à zéro il ya quelqu'un
qui s'occupe de la logistique
non merci merci et ça repart à aller
attention donc à billy bishop combien
860 80 49 49 julien parce qu'utoeya
parce qu'ils donnent pas tous gagnent
pas tous au début puisque le plus petit
score sera éliminé normalement tu
devrais passer deux côtés mais donne un
peu comme un moment donné ne donnent pas
tous de ne pas courir si ça donne pour
l'instant c'est sis aux 2 le putschiste
ont donné pas mal
le puissant de la base
[Applaudissements]
chose c'est bon attention vite ça puisse
y aller ou vite c'est au profit les
miens merci attendre à des baptêmes je
peux aller qu'a pu aller tous les
malades
alors on en voit la rumba bravo bravo
cap ne veux pas m'avancer mais ça pue
pour capturer 71 je ne le sens pas du
tout pas laisser retomber
je pense qu'on peut tout de suite
éliminer capital et samba attendait tout
simplement
[Applaudissements]
zéro attention ben je pense qu'on passe
à l'est près on passe au suivant sur soi
comme ça dans mon froc stéphanie vous
êtes éliminé les rouges et déjà délicat
mais c'est bon là c'est bon vous êtes
sûr jean michel saive ne crois pas
francky oui bien bien bien bien
il a beau tout ça mais aussi alessandra
les pêcheurs attendent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mcafee
maintenant 42 la piscine ah oui ça il
sait pas non mais l'avant
mollo 7,35 à retenir c'est qu'on est à
bata piscine la piscine au moins à
longvic de verre capucine aller là cette
fois la première batterie 300 au pas mal
lancée en dessous et en dessous soit 297
je le crée aussi un [ __ ] benjamin vous
n'avez pas le faire c'est bon je vois
pas comment il peut il peut faire moins
je pense que capucine est éliminé je
pense qu'on peut en bas on dépassera
tous les 300 attention venez s'il vous
plaît ceux qui sont encore en
compétition il reste trois jaunes et
trois rouges
attention c'est parti on repart
maintenant choisi il y a deux éliminés
comme ça en fera la demi-finale à terme
les élimine attention camille c'est à
vous et bim combat 858 éliminer ces
sciences que attention c'est pas un jour
mis un jaune mais on n'avait jamais tapé
c'est une fois qu il aura deux éliminés
retenez de l'année score s'il vous plaît
fera passer une techno
allez on y va pas mal oh la la
[Applaudissements]
pour l'instant les gens ni et 5 sont
éliminés par mettez-vous à côté en fait
comme un agent 1180 mois sans nom mais
on va voir
attention il y aura 2 à 10 minutes je
vais plus se serrer le compter dans un
instant
les séries on va se retrouver dans un
instant pour la suite
1 2 ils en pensent quoi qu'alibaba il y
aura d'autres épreuves les cherry à
prendre en charge directement avec
touche pas à mon poste avec soprano
fédéral voire à yale toute l'équipe fera
tout sourire elle continue à voter où tu
camille à tout
[Applaudissements]
c'est n'importe quoi calmer une balle et
on est dans votre ba ba je chéris nous
sommes en direct pendant 35 heures
si d'autres noms doivent nous regarder
un tweet et déjà on aura gagné dans un
instant qu'elle avait l'aval derrière la
place et mon médecin
çela au cas où au niveau de la voix je
peux pas parce que là on va atteindre
quand même cinq heures de direct
on est bientôt à 5 heures il ne restera
plus de 30 heures il ne restera plus qu
on est là c'est mon seul et ça a c'est
tout et c'est ça pour l'instant oui
c'est bien ça le reste pas devant la
télé
d'accord non il n'a pas livré de la dose
1,6 mais maintenant je les laisserais
tout à l'heure semble à tous j'ai oublié
sur bâton coquet bonjour autre chose
alors on est dans la merde
non non ça va faire la fête merci ce
long métrage aura tort camion rappelle
le principe mon chéri donc des épreuves
ton équipe l'équipe rouge un dock avec
benjamin castaldi bien sûr exxon rares à
stéphanie loire bonsoir à fabien
lecoeuvre et gilles verdez qui est dans
votre équipe qui sont en train de se
préparer pour l'épreuve d'après
exactement pour l'instant il ya trois
points pour monde urbain et nous sommes
à l'épreuve de force des rôles de force
qui devrait me sourire avec benjamin
castaldi et chacune et qui peuvent
encore m un point je rappelle hashtag
team camí au hashtag timba va parier sur
l'équipe qui vous pensez va gagner et
parmi les bonnes réponses un très beau
cadeau en fin d'émission pour l'un
d'entre vous sur twitter alors mon cas
mais pour l'instant il y aura deux
éliminés lors de cette session lors de
cette session
ceux qui ont déjà joué ce sont les trois
là donc jean michel julien et son nom
c'est pas moi qui ai joué c'est les deux
à vous avez fait combien vous 3 on a
joué pour l'instant
sachez battu les deux c'est pour
l'instant jean michel et sandra qui sont
éliminés d'accord ils ont fait combien
ils ont fait 754 à battre donc 654%
drahi l'heure actuelle combien comme un
voilà donc là il ya six ans julien alesi
faubert 787 all à la ferme où la jeune
mary pébereau
alors
white sandra s'est sauvé pour jean mi ça
serait donc jamie et chauve et pour
l'instant c'est julien la sauver
monsieur castany doit battre tomber un
plâtre le petit score de julien pasquier
500 autres faux pas de 650 cas puisque
julien est éliminée c'est sûr et certain
alors attention donc vous de vous êtes
éliminé brest 2 jaunes contre d'au
revoir à l'éliminer à chaque fois
maintenant c'est la folie c'est le taux
canvas open bar prince très petite
savate où tout va pour le mieux si on
arrête de rigoler maintenant de natation
à laisser partir deux secondes
laurens éliminé à chaque fois il ya un
moment pour tout attention c'est parti à
l'evo table
[Applaudissements]
camille combal 211 à battre je saute et
c'est pas grave j'ai pu mettre trop
d'élan jean-michel aller si jamais fade
away we go way c'est bon ça passe par un
bon score la jouer petit bras l'on n'a
pas du tout un tapage ahmad jouer parce
que c'est un membre de votre équipe
attention base arm à jouer donnez pas
non mais c'est vrai je n'ai pas que
donnait pas une pâte ou belges y passent
juste les bons scores de attention pas
mal pas mal
pour nous ça passe attention pour
l'instant donc je dors à 211
[Applaudissements]
provoc en bois attention il nous en
reste
l'ambition mise tout sur belge attention
jean-michel avant la demi-finale au coût
de 3 voilà il a ripé
il arrive même aux meilleurs 501 en
dessous de 551 à toi mon benji 550 angie
la pelouse jamais qu'un seul but en
finale c'est sûr mais au final je dois
battre face à moi bien au ciri l'a350
doit battre il s'est fait mal à la
mimine
la grande finale là bas la main je
rappelle attention à ton match j attends
ça ne va pas devoir parce que là les
jeunes les jeunes peuvent faire vraiment
le break à 4 points
magic system engineer m'a dit c'est bon
ça
allez hop éviter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon est-ce qu'il as qu'il a des épreuves
qui arrivent et qui compte double
j'entraîne c'est au tour des épreuves la
flore y ait des choses qui m'arrange
ils sont gagnants non mais c'est vrai
que là la cia les prochaines épreuves
bien sûr on va rappeler les scores les
chéris sachez qu'il jaune contre équipe
rongée pour l'instant il ya 4.1 pour la
timba bas face à la team camion hélas
hélas ya forcément une nouvelle épreuve
qui vaut deux points et voir je me fends
brouillé géré lui ont fait des preuves
qui vaut deux points et c2 de deux
participants des demandes de l'équipe
qui vous saute quand même pas bien je
vous souhaite quand même pas les noms
commencent il ya le break est fait et
moi de vous dire ça je vous sens quand
même pas tout il y en a un qui fnr mais
dont 11 qui va taper sur les gens
pendant toute la soirée c'est benjamin
et luce c'est un foot avec le lambada
parce que là la roja mais attendez non
mais là je respire je perds un ami et
que ces conneries comme ça je veux dire
comme on doit tout gagner maintenant et
non mais normalement il doit battre
différences balle à médard jamais la
chine nouvelle au bureau ce matin il a
dû s'entraîner il s'est pas entraîné
mais là on part de loin il faut comme ça
il est teigneux touche à ton cul
ses deux chroniqueurs d'eau qui vont
défendre les couleurs de leur équipe
on va jouer tout de suite au 110 m
attendait non mais je viens de voir les
looks dingler découvre les looks dans un
instant là je viens de vendre
[Applaudissements]
nous approchent
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît camille
je fais tu sais moi juste vous vous
n'avez pas besoin de cuba vous avez déjà
le match que tu vas tout l'équipement
ici hein mais lui c'est un truc de
malade à ce que nous rejoignent et c'est
vraiment là on va battre des records ce
soir est bien lui son retour et tout
veut vraiment vous êtes le seul gars
c'est à dire qu'il y en a tellement gros
paquet que regarder de profil sur la
tête de ma mère
son short il part comme ça sans réitérer
son short qui veut se barrer merci en
tout cas vous la tenue de cette chine
voit très bien alors on va calmer râpez
cette épreuve valoir expliqué c'est très
simple ils vont chacun représenté leur
équipe
c'est le 100 m palmes chacun avec vos
pas vous blesser pas gillois à les
arrachant allez-y mollo non mais je vous
jure
moi j'aimerais c'est ben non plus on
peut perdre ou même 4 un ça va
le principe il est très simple on va
faire ya le plateau de touche pas à mon
poste juste à côté puisque cyril sera en
direct aussi dans un instant vous allez
partir faire le tour du plateau de
touche pas à mon poste et revenir par ce
côté est le premier des deux qui re
franchir à nouveau cette ligne elle
viendra un poisson alors juste faudrait
rappeler juste les règles j'ai moins
qu'un cadre heures qui viennent avec
nous juste on m'a rappelé le parcours et
mes chéris je vous le dis donc il va
falloir passer ça ça donc le premier
donc qui ne sera pas décédée donc
viendra et gagnera l'épreuve parce que
là les mecs j'ai peur de l'accident
ali mahmoud rouleau en plus vous les
palmes sont plus grandes que vous je
sais que je suis de 5,6 à gré
cali est ce qu'il faudrait pas de faire
inscrire un chrono il faut le parcours
chacun leur taux auquel j'ai peur j'ai
peur que les poussettes tout ça que ce
soit en chine vers nos amis des
brassards alors moi je propose que l'on
démarre et fans au local allez c'est
parti mon fantasme d'un chronomètre
autres escrocs nos attentions alain
croteau et camille il faut absolument
que vous gagnez cette épreuve parce que
sinon il y aura cinq points d'un et ça
va être dur de review il ya trois points
en jeu
donc là laurent 2 et fabien fabien met
le paquet attention c'est le 100 m pas
le fabien le plus important ne se blesse
pas et je préfère que tu prennes 3
secondes et fabien juste fait nous
dessine ce que quand vous allez passer
derrière la table avant vous verra plus
on est encore là juste là ça devient
juste tout va bien attention on y prie 3
2 1 dans le débat
d'abord à gameiro
ou pas
[Applaudissements]
en vain
avec 7,1
[Musique]
je suis fair play je vous enlève deux
secondes parce que vous avez été gêné
par la caméra qui suit secondes et vous
avez vu c'est le seul gars quand même
ils se déplacent comme ça puisque comme
ça forcément il serait happé par l'avant
bah oui avec l'agglo mais c'est vrai
forcément y'a emplois ici l'euphorie
projeter vers l'avant et qui le ferait
bien sûr tomber mais on l'avait bien
compris les autobus et bien sûr d'eux se
déplaçant crabe en même temps aime aussi
le jour mais c'est normal sinon ils ne
passent pas la personne ne passe pas
j'essaie de tout âge il ne te laisse pas
au mieux non mais en plus on est pas le
nez en avant en aérodynamique attention
à 3 2
[Applaudissements]
ah la la
c'est un second candidat c'est galère
bonjour
l excellent allez je sais donc à mon
pupitre dressé par le gpad si vous nous
rejoignez on est en direct c'est la
folie c'est les 35 heures un ballon va
faire 35 heures de direct j'espère que
vous vous amusez autant que nous on a
envie de vous changer les idées et on va
continuer parce qu'il y aura toutefois
en poste dans un instant il ya le sait
pour nous c'est cadeau ce soir de fou il
ya du poste de surveillance
après ce soir il y aura une émission
avec plein de records et vous battrez
des records et puis ce soir toute la
nuit jusqu'à trois heures du matin en
fait je vous prendre au téléphone
vous verrez dormir parce que servir à 10
ans qui sera ensemble vers et voilà
trois heures du matin jusqu'à 5h
écartelé dormir mais je serai toujours à
l'antenne et ensuite on fait le morning
demain fait la matinale dès 6h du matin
matinal sur s'est vite bien sûr 6h10
heure les chéris après on enchaîne y
aura plein d'autres émissions dont on va
vous parler pour le moment
merci points dans ces points de reims
tenez je crois que c'est à vous il avait
perdu quelque chose et merci merci et je
rappelle bien sûr à ceux qui nous
écoutent s'il ya un ensemble hi fi vidéo
rennais puisqu'il ya des choses à gagner
on a oublié de le dire c'est vrai qu'on
voudra dire bravo à mathieu brenna qui
gagne un séjour au ski d'une semaine
puisqu'il a joué au jeu audiotel ou
parution nature
ça c'était un ami alors là c'est une
épreuve qui me tient extrêmement à coeur
et vous allez voir vous allez l'adorer
cette épreuve le seul truc c'est qu'il
faut un billard donc on a eu la chance
d'en ramener un va louer ces deux-là
look mais il n'y a que deux boules c'est
vous cela on est tête à tête assis toi
vous contre moi tronche à tronche on a
on arrête de mettre des gens seront
d'accord parce que si on avait besoin de
boule y en a toujours un cadeau alors
oui donc amis on va expliquer aux
téléspectateurs ce qui va se passer je
vais expliquer alors c'est déjà c'est le
un jeu très célèbre c'est vraiment
l'intention absolut cyril on ya joué
tout l'été c'est le gars rataboul jingle
essayer des séries va vous expliquer
c'est lui qui a créé le jeu diarra cap
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
juste camus on s'apprête donc tous les
deux combien de quoi trois points trois
points vous voulez que cette épreuve val
combien pour un petit point parce que
vous êtes mené 5 points à rejeter
propose un froid elle veut elle vaut 3
pour elle elle vaut 3 c sur votre
terrain je suis fait renoncer pas mon
terrain et je n'ai plus de terrain
aujourd'hui
alors les chéris c'est très simple
regardez je vous montre il va falloir
donc faire partir la boule c'est ça un
cas ni la boule tape là bas
tapez une bande au bout et qu'elle
revienne le plus proche dit si elle peut
taper 1 et qu'elles soient le plus
proche de la voilà cette bande est ce
donc là j'ai fait un coup de mer par
exemple hockey est un jeu très addictif
à une fois grunge une fois on peut plus
s'arrête alors qu'amy attention c'est à
vous allez très vite comprendre on va
jouer
camille vous démarrez voulait faire un
essai d'abord peut-être comme moi j'en
ai fait un aller comme je suis fermée
aujourd'hui mettre la pression on voit
la place pour montrer je suis pas venu
là pour rigoler non plus voilà donc là
par exemple quand vous êtes pas mal
voilà vous êtes pas mal il faudra que je
fasse mieux avec la boule au liban j'y
vais j'y vais premier coup citant trois
points 53 points gagnants rappel c'était
pas vos trois points mais je suis pas
l'habitude je n'ai pas l'habitude sur
cette menace est là et l'a même pas
touché non
ainsi si on a le droit pas tout
attention
c'est normal cette musique brésilienne
je ne vois pas le rapport médical allez
belle allée 1.1 point pour quelques
zéros à bout à bout vous démarrez
terrienne à la boule de notre couleur
lacées mode emma attention c'est vrai
qu'on a pris les boulots règle est
vraiment très grand on est vraiment très
à la gare je suis jolie brune blonde
elle est très belle partie oui c'est un
mois notamment de la bande un point
marqué
sauf qu'on peut jouer deezer est bon
c'est beau un côté blanc est faiblard
mais ça peut passer mais ça peut passer
on va passer est très belle au point
d'un attention de poison a provoqué 2.1
pour vous allez-y fin de match attention
au lay laraque qui a raté sa boule comme
on dit dans le milieu
c'est raté mais pas si mal elle est pas
génial mais il faut aller chercher à 2.1
pour vous si je fais moins bien vous
aurez gagné cette épreuve
si je fais mieux deux points partout et
on aura une dernière boule exactement
pour des parties se jouer au mental
toujours un peu fourbe pas fait gaffe on
est belle s'il touche maboul salle avant
ça y est
attention c'est ce qu'on appelle dans le
milieu la dernière boule elle est calme
il y à deux points partout on rappelle
les scores il ya cinq ans un si vous
gagnez cette épreuve vous pourrez
revenir à 5 points à 4 ouais non il ya
alors je vous rappelle qu'un +3 égale 4
capucine merci à tous et gagne c'est la
dernière boule on a la pression
c'est horrible mon cas mais on va se
retrouver dans un instant on va se
retrouver dans un instant pour la
dernière boule qui va gagner le gars
rataboul et je pense que celui qui va
gagner le gard à kaboul sera le grand
gagnant gagnera je pense est olympien
oui c'est très possible mais c'est pas
sûr et je voudrais remercier tout cas de
lawrence d'arabie d'être avec nous
gilles verdez on se donnera l'instant
les pousser les et on enchaînera tout de
suite et on vient de passer les six
heures
curieux ont fait écouter
[Musique]
somme de re souvent d'antispam a aussi
annoncé la fin du spot à les regarder
je vais vous montrer ce que vous montrez
tout le monde est prêt à regarder tout
le monde est là voilà le plateau est
prêt les chroniqueurs vont arriver dans
un instant garde
s'il est là comme vous le voyez on
prépare l'émission il y aura ayem ayem
martial tenir à son image de média
regardez-moi celui-ci qui est en train
de préparer des choses il aura des
mamies c'est bon les savoirs merci et et
il y aura ce soir dans tout ce soir mon
poste des vérités et des dar k les
chroniqueurs vont arriver dans un
instant pour le moment où sommes en
pleine compétition avec camille combal
amont camille on en pleine compet on va
rappeler les scores on va rappeler
principe de l'émission
si vous nous rejoignez sachez qu'on a
déjà fait six heures de sicile direction
5h dgac
ouais on est à cinq heures de direct
puisqu'il est et il est déjà 19h10 sont
pratiquement sa part 5 heures de direct
à 5 heures de direct de fait il ya mille
euros pour l'association c'est que du
bonheur donc on est à 5000 euros pour le
moment il nous reste plus que 30 heures
à faire et bien sûr on vous offre des
cadeaux puisque nous sommes en direct et
tous et 8,1 s'est mis au diapason pour
vous faire des cadeaux il ya déjà un
garçon qui est parti un séjour au ski et
mon mathieu on a on a notre dos c'est
magnifique on vous offre
écoutez bien pendant ses 35 heures plus
de 20000 euros de cadeaux à gagner plein
de cadeaux week end pour quatre
personnes en pension complète on a plein
de trucs et nouvelle question vous êtes
très bien sûr nouvelle questionnant même
question mais un nouveau gagnant pour un
très très beau cadeau maintenant fait on
n'a fait qu'une question exactement vous
envoyer baba par sms au 73 2 838 vous
appelez le 39 27 tout de suite pour
partie avec un très très beau cadeau à
celle à qui la commission est très
simple cyril a un surnom est ce que
c'est abba ou est-ce que c'est hathaway
à vous de deviner tout par sms le 73 838
à l'est pour le moment
pour le moment les séries
pour le moment il y à l'équipe jaune qui
est mon équipe pour l'instant et on
caracole en tête dans ces épreuves il ya
5.1 pour le moment cette épreuve là
dugas rataboul vos trois pour le
seigneur vous pourriez revenir voir
revenir le mag - za 4 et revenir dans le
match qu'il y aura une dernière épreuve
juste après tout peut basculer les
chéris on était à deux points partout
o'gara tabou l'on va rappeler principe
faut lancer la boule la boule peut doit
taper ici et revenir le plus proche de
ce bord là elle peut toucher un atout
sur l'instant il ya deux points partout
camille attention pour voir qui démarre
pas ce que je vais choisir puisque
maintenant c'est le point décisif
attention chifoumi le pierre kast le
ciseau c'est donc vous qui débarque je
préférais démarrer elle va très bien
mais où est alors attention ça va se
jouer sur cette boule sur cette boule à
il a fait une très belle elle écrivait
elle est très belle et wajir site
[Applaudissements]
il a fait je dois le dire une très belle
boule et dieu sait que les belles boules
ça n'est pas son truc normalement alors
j'ai deux solutions ou bien je la tente
de faire mieux ou bien j'essaie de
pousser la tienne
je crois que l'une dans l'autre on va
prendre trois points ça va vite se
régler
attention nous mettre en confiance les
belles elle est très belle
en coupant
[Applaudissements]
tout à fait
regardez tu vois d'ici on la voit mieux
mes encadreurs voix l'a démontré on la
voit bien à bâle est très belle oh non
mais je vais tenir
je les ai vus partir je savais qu'elle
gagne non c'est pas cher elle était elle
est excitée c'était pas la première fois
que tu vois partir des me vous l'avez
compris l'équipe de serre il a largement
gagné ce soir on essaiera de faire une
revanche peut-être demain en tout cas
vous avez joué à stein et moi camillo
hashtags imbaba tout ce qu'on jouait sur
steam baba vous avez bien fait puisque
tout de suite parmi tous les gens qui
ont misé sur la timba bas une personne
va repartir avec une très belle tablette
on va regarder déjà les résultats
surtout nous afficher des résultats qui
avaient parié sur la timba bas alors
voilà 69% vous avez senti le vent
tourner et balade entre yahia alors je
vais recueillir les impressions de
chacun c'est un peu comme comme dans koh
lanta si vous devez vous deviez voilà
des signes est le meilleur et le moins
bon de ces de toutes ces épreuves
benjamin voilà dans votre équipe dans
votre équipe qui vous apporte des
pressions a dit oui qui vous a porté
préjudice à jamin donc préjudice aux
personnes
alors vous êtes déçu vous êtes déçu non
pas du tout dans notre équipe le
meilleur combal ouais on parlait du
moins bon mais le meilleur le meilleur
si gentiment lui veut garder son poste
on ans camille combal et peut-être la
moins bonne
où l'on parle bien sûr dans les épreuves
dans les haies pour la peine je fais pas
ça se joue entre les deux vous vous êtes
senti à la hauteur à il est où des
boules ça dépend du ray stéphanie c'est
à dire l'équivalent de rillieux zh
est ce que vous avez peut-être un
message à passer à l'équipe adverse
qu'est-ce qu'on pourriez leur dire 'vous
gilles verdez ils se sont vraiment
moquer nous dès que les équipes ont été
désignés ils ont été insultant et n'ont
que ce qu'ils méritent aucune pitié qui
a quitté pour vous les a fait perdre le
plus c'est tous des tocards mais tout
honteux car oui c'est tous des tocards
mais fabien le pire des cas vous
capucine va dans notre équipe
c'est gilles ce qui nous a bien sauvé
était formidable vraiment bravo chine
c'est vraiment et sinon bah moi j'ai non
mais je parlais de votre équipe puisque
vous merci on vous raconte pas on vous
interviewera demain vous allez
participer je les aime beaucoup faut
qu'il soit faire plein parce que bon on
était meilleur mais bon peut-être demain
peut-être demain dont la tête j'y crois
pas trop demain mais on verra quand même
un lendemain il y aura des épreuves
qu'on a fait aujourd'hui qu'ils ont été
un peu le t il y aura aussi deux
nouvelles épreuves qui seront peut-être
un peu plus à mon avantage hanouna
arrêtez les gars à tabu ley l'économie
sont les épreuves un petit peu de
défense belges que ça donnait ça vient
pas je vais le faire d'ici demain avant
le nom de la gagnante à m
le nom de la gagnante anaheim olalala et
je vis baba je le mange d'emballage
membres acceptent leur machine
une tablette one et on a on a pas fini
avec ses directs dans un astoria tout
doucement mon poste après il ya c'est
pour nous c'est cadeau touche pas à mon
poste formidable je vous dis aura ayem
qui va venir nous voir pour le mag
il ya soprano trois mois elle va mettre
à l'eau jeudi mais vraiment le fire du
jean-michel de vous laisser le gros de
la fin jean-michel qu'est ce que vous
avez à dire à l'autre équipe
ils m'ont absolument pas déçu parce que
j'ai jamais cru en eux au fond du tiroir
nous pas s'attendre non plus à faire des
exploits donc oui moi je tiens à dire
que si on avait eu des épreuves intello
on vous aurait mis on devrait la mission
sur wii on a eu des preuves avec des
questions n'est pas répondu merci madame
merci on se retrouveront demain demain
pour ils en pensent quoi camille baba
alla revanche the revenge l'oeil du
tigre c'est que je me refuse à mon chéri
currie s'accroche qu'on va faire le
débriefing barrière est avec nous on se
retrouve dans un instant pour à tous pas
mon poste de folie et après on enchaîne
directement
on est en direct c'est les 35 heures
rémi tessier
il nous en reste
[Applaudissements]
comme attendu red bull à trois autres
avec du sang neuf voilà
[Applaudissements]
bon
depuis 14h alors si votre personnage
[Applaudissements]
enfin la salle interplateaux c'est que
prend ta tout seul l'ensemble en direct
sur ses 8 ans doit battre le record bien
sûr des 35 heures 1 35 heures donc
d'antenne ça n'a jamais été fait à la
télévision française
voilà donc il faudra qu'on aille
ailleurs après voilà une fois que je
vois la pakistan je pense qu'on on le
fera dans un instant on aura soprano qui
sera avec nous ça va être la folie
on aura cette séquence que vous nous
réclamer des dark a aidé à lutter car
mon matthieu delormeau aimant partira en
toute fin d'émission parce qu on
enchaînera direct avec c'est pour nous
c'est cadeau et je peux vous dire qu'on
a c'est pour nous c'est cadeau de folie
ce soir je vous dis aura des cadeaux de
fou à bâtir camille et la ronde et en
plus pour vous je voulais juste qu'on
fasse un petit débris des 35 heures pour
l'instant si vous avez vu parce que
comme camille en fait voilà on a fait 1
1 camille un peu spécial voilà qu'est ce
que vous pensez pour l'instant des 35
heures est ce que vous aimez comme ça
qu'on soit en direct comme ça sur une
chaîne tout le temps avec
d'accompagnement moi je je je pense
qu'on tient un truc 20 mois je pourrais
pas le faire tous les jours vous l'a dit
mais franchement - jean-luc moi j'adore
les défis j'aime bien vous faites votre
tête parce qu'au bout de cinq sets face
à wayne reste plus de 30 heures dégâts
mais c'est vrai comment vous allez tenir
mais franchement c'est très dur parce
que déjà cinq heures là ça commence à
être chaud mais ça 5h30 vous le sentez
que ça commence à trop jouer les petits
yeux non je pense qu'il faut pas
s'habituer à vos yeux les verts un peu
demain donc
non mais c'est vrai que c'est du coa sur
moi mon coeur c'est un problème
oui merci il avait bien qu'on voit à
quel point on est endurant
ah ouais donc mais effectivement si
juste les yeux qui trahissent c'est la
lumière
ça doit être ça répare montrer on
travaille dans la lah avant vous et des
émissions dans le noir maintenant on est
dans la lumière
on entre dans la lumière week-end passé
c'est sur les yeux que cette portion des
jeunes
je vous dis ricaine pas c'est vrai c'est
sont les yeux que ça se porte surtout
donc il faut pas que je ricane n'ont pas
d'accord si je vous ai pas vus depuis
trois jours donc c'est vrai que je me
connais je ne vous connais plus merci
benhaim on était ensemble tous les prix
moyens ont lancé régaliens oui c'était
vraiment très très sympa fait attention
bonne voie parce que c'est la voix aussi
qui trinquent beaucoup quand on parle
c'est toujours le docteur a créé là à
côté il est où le docteur d'ailleurs le
docteur il est ou allô docteurs et la
regarder et le docteur qui est là avec
moi depuis 5h un déjà de cinq heures de
temps ça fait depuis 14h qui avec moi ça
va d'autres on voit très bien très bien
merci les bienvenus vous êtes vraiment
docteur oui oui
parce que voilà on a peur voilà on a
peur bon mathieu rue chez lui comme
s'est ému ses bons copains quoi est ce
mon copain mais qui est docteur quoi car
ici votre compagne de karbaoui nom mais
qui sait pas ce qui s'est passé entre
vous ah c'est un gériatre
[Applaudissements]
passez votre copain karim sur pékin
express et on est restés amis et
d'ailleurs je voulais te rappeler mais
les civils des soucis vous voulez pas
l'appeler après parce que vous mettez
tout le monde en fait comme je voulais
lui dire tout à l'heure et de l'appeler
ben la voilà c'est superbe arrêt
jean-luc que c'était comme ça quand
j'étais pas là malheureusement oui
merci bonjour comment ça se fait le
parce que moi je viens d'arriver il donc
il ya quand même un monsieur qui fait
beaucoup de bruit
oui parce que c'est pas humiliant lui
avoir enlevé une roue est ce qu il
ferait plaisir un moment non mais c'est
beaucoup de bruit non mais c'est vrai
ceret bravo en tout cas et on va dire ce
qui a été dit [ __ ] de booster bon
mathieu vous nous disiez être ému par
ces 35 heures de direct
non pas vraiment parler de 25 heures de
direct ufmd ému par ce que ce après midi
je vais regarder évidemment du bureau
j'ai appris la nouvelle
pas vrai qu'on attendait un petit à oui
c'est le voyant là on n'était qu'un
voyant tuer leur pelouse d'al hilal
existe il m'a dit que j'attendais un
enfant ben oui donc je ne sais pas de
qui je l'espère comme en courant mais
ils arrivent ils arrivent dans puis
enfin la rue pour vous c'est le
troisième mois ça sera le premier dont
une part non mais un tu es venu mais on
n'a pas pu le faire ensemble
là je ne sais pas mais en tous les cas
il est bien de quelque part nous c'est
pas possible le soir je reprenne la
biologie au départ tout est au pire peu
importe je m'occuperai comme si c'était
le mien ça oui vraiment très bien elle
va lui il s'occupe des enfants dans la
voiture et on est tous d'accord
géraldine vous bonsoir bonsoir c'est la
seule boeuf est à croire qu elle en
boîte de nuit bonsoir oui j'ai peur pour
vous en faites
ah oui pourquoi j'ai peur de cette
surexposition médiatique je pense qu'on
peut pas être à la fois endurant
explosif peut pas être usain bolt est
libre et c'est l'acier ou le connaissez
bien sûr un grand marathonien je connais
et je crois que je croyais que c'était
quoi la veste est une métaphore sportive
vous avez des supports j'adore ça ah
ouais on pensait danse et où on va vite
et on fait les choses rapidement
non peut pas être bon et endurant ni
explosifs ni endurance c'est pas
possible c'est incompatible
c'est pas mal on n'y avait pas pensé à
ça eh bien écoutez est laquelle le
record donc on arrête tout
merci vous ont mis tout le monde le sait
vous êtes un homme d'exploit il fallait
que vous marquez un peu plus vous vous
êtes à la télévision beaucoup de code
c'est vrai il y aura un avant et un
après personne n'a osé le faire ce que
c'est hyper fatiguant ce que les jours
où ça paye fait très très chaud sur le
plateau sont au bout du rouleau
c'est l'intention de tout laisser perdre
une dent tout à l'heure on va recoller
au plus
bientôt une couille je ne sais pas si on
va bien rigoler mais bon en tout cas et
et monk amis qui étaient avec moi ils en
pensent quoi camille baba de mayer alors
il y aura la revanche du roi la revanche
contre sur la fatigue pour tordre on
verra ça de la salle bain
mais pour le moment on restera touche
pas à mon poste et je peux vous dire
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à voir ces
partis générique la débauche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]